je vous propose un petit jeu euh un
ingrédient par personne citez-moi la
composition de cette tarte à la fraise
s'amuser pour démystifier un univers
parfois obscur pour sa tournée à travers
les régions françaises le camion
itinérant l'aventure du vivant s'est
stationné aux clés sous-bois ce jeudi 30
novembre lancé par le ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire ce dispositif présente plus
de 200 professions et 150 formations du
secteur agricole éleveur conseiller
technique ou maréchal ferrand l'objectif
est d'initier au plus grand nombre la
richesse de ce secteur on est là euh
surtout pour remettre au goût du jour
casser les les clichés et et les anciens
codes dans le sens où euh il faut se
réapproprier la culture de manière
générale l'idée c'est de découvrir de
voir le panel de métiers qui existe et
et ensuite si c'est intéressent de les
réorienter de le rediriger vers
établissements de participer de faire
des journées pouroutouvertes simulateur
de tracteur casque de réity virtuel ou
quiz dans ce camion de 18 m de long les
animateurs présentent ses emplois de
façon ludique pour séduire un jeune
public de la formation technique à celle
d'ingénieur l'enseignement agricole
touche de nombreux profils ben moi je
voyais que c'était plus un métier manuel
compliqué
et voilà je savais pas du tout queil
pouvait y avoir autant de technologie ce
que je retiens vraiment c'est que il y a
énormément de métier et c'est pas que le
dans la ferme c'est aussi à l'extérieur
c'est scientifique ce sont des métiers
qui sont mal connus qui sont surtout en
devenir on le sait et comme là nous
avons des classes de 4e 3e ça les
concerne vraiment eux pour pouvoir
trouver des débouchés quand il ser ront
au lycée et pour plus tard pour mieux
concrétiser cette expérience auprès des
collégiens l'association pleine de
Versailles présentait des formations
agricoles dans des écoles locales de son
côté le camion l'aventure du vivant est
à retrouver au gymnase Jean Guimier
jusqu'au 2 décembre
prochain